we're asked to categorize the value of
each exponential expression and we
categorize each expression into either
the bucket less than negative 1 between
negative 1 & 0 and between 0 & 1 and I
encourage you to pause this video and
try this out on your own so I assume
you've given a go at it now let's work
through it together so I just copy and
pasted the exact same exercise right
over here and let's think about each of
these expressions and actually before
doing that I actually want to draw a
number line to think about these
categories so it looks like the
important things to consider you have a
0 you have 1 and then you have negative
1 this first category right over here
less than negative 1 that's all of these
values right over there then you have
the category between negative 1 & 0
that's these values right over there and
then finally you have the category
between 0 & 1
that's this category right over here so
they didn't give us a bucket for greater
than 1 so I guess it's safe to assume
that none of these are going to be a
greater than 1 but let's go each
expression by each expression so this
first expression 7 to the negative
fourth power 7 to the negative fourth
power we've already talked about several
times when you raise something to a
negative exponent this isn't somehow
negative 7 to the fourth power or
anything like that this is the 6 when
you see an exponent when you see a
negative number an exponent you should
immediately think reciprocal so this is
going to be equal to 1 over 7 to the
positive 4th power and you don't even
have to know what 7 to the 4th actually
is it's 2,401 and if you're interested
but you don't even have to know that you
just know that this right over here is
going to be a large positive number so 1
over that is going to be a very small
positive number it's going to be between
0 & 1 this is actually 1 2,401 but you
don't even have to know that this is a
large number and so you say well this is
going to get pretty close it's going
it's positive so it's going to be above
0 but it's not going to be too much
above 0 is gonna sit on the number line
actually I'm not even doing justice
right over there the way I've drew it
scale it's you know not even a pixel to
the right
of zero right over there so this is
going to be between between zero and one
now and actually I'll draw lines like
this to show where it roughly on our
number line where it would sit now let's
think about negative seven to the third
power so negative seven to the third
power well this is the same thing as
negative 7 times negative 7 times
negative 7 and you could also think
about this as negative 1 times 7 times
negative 1 times 7 times negative 1
times 7 which is the same thing as you
have three negative ones being
multiplied together so negative 1 to the
third power times 7 to the third power
well what's negative 1 to the third
power well it's negative 1 times
negative 1 which should be positive 1
but then times another negative 1 so
this is negative 1 right over here so
this is going to be equal to negative
now let me write it this way you could
write it easier as negative I could
write it like this that negative 7 to
the third power so 7 to the third once
again we don't even have to know what it
is this is going to be a large positive
value but then we're negating it if we
had 7 to the 3rd it would be greater
than 1 but negative 7 to the 3rd is
definitely less than negative 1 so this
fits into that bucket right over there
now we have negative 7 to the negative
4th negative 7 to the negative 4th so
let me write it over here so negative 7
to the negative fourth and this could be
a little daunting because you have a
negative base raised to a negative
exponent but whenever we see whenever I
see a negative exponent the first thing
I worry about what first thing my brain
wants to do is take a reciprocal so this
is going to be 1 over negative 7 1 over
negative 7 to the fourth power and once
again the same ideas we just saw over
here we could view this as 1 over
negative 1 to the fourth power times 7
to the fourth power which is going to be
equal to negative 1 to the fourth power
this is just going to be equal to 1 so
this is going to be equal to 1 over 7 to
the
worth power well we've already thought
about what 1 over 7 to the 4th power is
it is between it is between 0 & 1 so
this right over here is between is
between 0 & 1 another way you could
think about it this is going to be 1
over negative 7 times negative 7 times
negative 7 times negative 7 you have a
negative times a negative times a
negative times a negative well that's
going to be a positive so it's positive
7 to the fourth power now let's think
about this one right over here negative
7 to the negative fifth power so let me
write this out negative 7 to the
negative fifth power
well once again as soon as you see that
negative exponent I I want to just take
the reciprocal so I don't have a
negative exponent anymore so it's 1 over
negative 7 to the fifth power and we
could rewrite this as 1 over negative 1
to the 5th times negative 7 or sorry
times 7 to the 5th times 7 to the 5th
which is equal to well what's negative
what's a negative 1 to the fifth power
well a negative 1 raised to an odd power
is going to be a negative 1 so this is
going to be negative 1 over 7 to the
fifth power
so where is 1 over 7 to the fifth power
well that would be really close to 0
this would be positive 1 over 7 to the
fifth would be a very small positive
number but now we're taking the negative
of that so we're going to jump on to the
other side of 0 so this is going to be
between negative 1 and 0 2 negative 1
and 0 and then finally negative 7 to the
fifth power well that's just going to be
this once again you could view that as
negative 1 times 7 to the fifth power
which is the same thing as negative 1 to
the 5th times 7 to the 5th which is the
same thing as negative 7 to the 5th 7 to
the 5th is a very large number larger
than 1 so the negative of that is going
to be a very negative number it's going
to be less than negative 1 so this is
going to be less
and negative one right over here so now
let's take our results and since I have
a bad memory I must since you probably
have to think through it again now let's
actually put them in the buckets 7 to
the negative 4th power this is not going
to be in negative value this is 1 over 7
to the 4th this is going to be between 0
& 1 negative 7 to the third power that's
essentially if you take 7 to the 3rd
power you get a very large positive
number but then it since it's you're
gonna that's going to be times negative
1 to the 3rd power it's going to be the
negative version of that so that's going
to be less than negative 1 negative 7 to
the negative 4th well we already
determined especially because this is
and this ends up being 1 over negative 7
to the 4th power and that's an even
exponent it ends up being the same as 7
to the negative 4th and then you had
negative 7 to the negative fifth power
so once again that was going to be 1
over negative 7 to the 5th power and so
we found that to be between negative 1
and a zero and then finally this right
over here is going to be it's going to
be negative and it's going to be a very
negative number it's less than negative
1 and so those are our choices and we
can check our answer and we got it right